- Every day, I turn off
onto an old country road.
It's about a mile from the
presidents, but you can see 'em.
And then you get up to 'em
and you stand next to one
and you go, "Man, these things are huge!"
How many people on Earth can
say they got a collection
of presidents in their backyard
that you can see from space?
(playful orchestral music)
I know there's JFK. (laughing)
I have 43 presidents.
And Ronald.
These guys weigh approximately
14,000 to 21,000 pounds.
These things are huge, aren't they?
They've been here for about three years.
And through time, they're
starting to enjoy being out here.
They've got their wildlife.
Wow, got a bees' nest.
The weeds are growing up and
it's amazing; they amaze me.
These statues were once
a part of a outdoor park.
When the original park
had closed its doors,
I was asked to destroy the presidents
and clean the place up.
It hit me.
I said, "I'm not destroying 'em.
"I'm gonna figure out something."
The feeling I get from
'em, it’s, it’s overwhelming.
I mean, these guys, they
still have strength today
that they had when they were
alive and forming our country.
They mean a lot to me.
I wanna bring 'em back to a museum
where they can be enjoyed by everybody.